I had studied acting at Boston
University was my goal my whole life I
wanted to be an actor they they didn't
tell us if he wanted to be in movies
that you should go to LA everybody else
was going to New York and so I went
there too and I was like how am I
supposed to get in a movie and so I had
this brilliant idea that because
Christie Brinkley and Lauren Hutton and
people like that who been models were in
in movies and I thought I'll just become
a model and then they will just hire me
simple because it's always easier to
become a supermodel this is literally my
plan so I did become a model um I was
even on a cover of New Jersey Monthly I
was a great success so so when they were
casting tutsi evidently Lynn called
modeling agency because the characters
in her underwear allow he called Molly
ages and said do you have any models who
can act and they were like Gina they
want a bottle who could act and so i got
i went to the audition it was my first
audition ever and right and i went there
and it was like an assistant or somebody
with a video camera and they read the
scene with you and I did whatever and
they had said they want you to wear a
bathing suit under your clothes because
if you read well they're going to ask to
see you in a bathing suit but they
didn't ask me about you know it just
went out of my mind because what are the
odds you're gonna get the job on your
first edition and so I went off to
Europe to do the fashion shows whatever
and Lynn saw my tape and really liked it
he showed it to Sydney [ __ ] and
Sydney he also agreed and it said but
where's her bathing suit photos or
whatever and he said oh no and she's got
she's in Europe we can't get her well
does she have any photos of herself in a
bathing suit so fortunately I had been
in victoria's secret catalog
so instead of whoever else auditioned
and took their clothes off in their sad
bathing suit with the fluorescent lights
uh I was in these airbrushed pictures
with hahaha I got fog machines and
everything I got the part Sydney Sydney
[ __ ] was assistant to to Sandy
Meisner her no no the great the great
casting the great acting coach in New
York sandy Meisner sanding on yeah and
Sydney [ __ ] used to sleep in this is
is auntie room and he knew more about
acting and about actors than any other
director I know right yeah it was
extraordinary and it was a fine actor
himself in the early stages of your
career on your way to receiving an Oscar
for the accidental tourist how were your
experiences with casting and casting
directors you know casting directors are
everything obviously my god what an
incredible thing to be in a movie
directed by Sydney [ __ ] on with
Dustin Hoffman it couldn't get better I
don't know how it would ever get better
maybe if I had more clothes on but the
next thing that happened to me before
the movie came out was I got cast in the
TV show Buffalo Bill with Dabney Coleman
and so I got to move to LA finally
realizing where I should be with a TV
series and movie in the can so that just
was it was everything it was everything
that every door opened because of those
two events I think Lynn was very keen to
to help actors that he felt strongly
about their talent and to and to see
them prosper in a very generous way
right as a testament to the kind of
support that Lynn's given to actors